you think and so you genuinely believe
that women shouldn't be allowed to vote
well okay I'm gonna caveat this okay I
don't think it's likely this will ever
happen yeah I'm never really gonna
campaign for this to have like how could
nowadays however I think the outcomes
would be better
okay and now this goes back into the
documentary that I'm making so I'm
making a documentary on um the court
system here in the UK I wish I brought
my notebook because
I have it all laid out in my I should
have brought my notebook I didn't but um
the issue in the UK is that
men only get custody of their kids 10 of
the time
would you agree that's crazy
yes would you agree if it's if your kid
you should get 50 50 custody it depends
off the bat it depends well I actually
don't agree okay go ahead and I'll tell
you why I don't agree with it and this
will make me very problematic because
I'm suggesting that men and women are
different but as someone who has a a
young child
they're way better off with their mother
on average under the age of eight over
the age of eight the kids have better
outcomes with the father single single
father homes have significantly better
outcomes than singles under the age of
eight though they need the mother true
but it's okay specific because if the
mother is a psycho then no and if the
father is abusive then no right or has
addiction issues or whatever else I
personally think that it's 50 50 it's 50
his DNA he should off the bat be
entitled to 50 50 custody now they could
talk about it based on his work schedule
and then switch it you know but off the
bat 50 50 custody would you agree that
10 of the time men getting access to
their children being the primary custody
hold like that's that's insane there's a
lot of problems with the the way that
divorce is handled Etc I mean I know
people who uh someone who was married
for a couple of years
they were both professional people
working uh her career and income were
not in any way affected
and then they divorced after a couple of
years and she got a ton of his
money for no reason yeah I'll
tell you about this guy that I
interviewed yesterday and it's going to
tie into the voting thing but it's just
going to take a second so he has three
daughters okay three and he was married
to a good girl for 10 years
um she was like of a Muslim background
so they had like the same does that make
sense background yeah of course
um he
um
the the marriage ended right and all of
a sudden there was a restraining order
put out against him and an allegation of
abuse
why was there allegations of abuse
because in the UK you get free lawyers
if you claim that the man abused you so
now he has to pay for a house that's not
his
okay so he has to because the house is
in his name and he's kicked out of the
house because of the restraining order
he doesn't have access to his kids and
on top of that he has to pay child
support every month he loses his job
because he's so I mean he just a lot
he's homeless now loses his job he
doesn't have access to his kids because
he's working in um like electricity or
something and it's like a very high
stress job and like you can't have a guy
that's yeah yeah he's not focused yeah
yeah yeah so he now he loses his job now
his option is he goes to the lawyers
right and the lawyers
um he has two choices he can either
accept the restraining order and
acceptance it plead guilty basically to
abuse or he can pay 20 to 30 000 pounds
and fight for his kids and the odds he
gets his kids is 10 and this time the
mom is no longer letting him see the
kids they're a mile away from him three
daughters he hasn't seen them in a year
and a half
so what happens next
um he tries to fight now now he's broke
and he goes to court and the problem is
these girls go to women's shelters and
at the women's shelters they have they
basically know the system of how to get
the most money and the most time with
the kids right
and the other issue with the lawyers is
that because they get free counsel from
the women's shelter what incentive do
they have to really help the guy I mean
their number one clients are women
so a lot of these men are given bad
advice in court
so now um it takes them a year and a
half to even be able to fight the
restraining order to even get a chance
to get access to his children
like he he and remember just one phone
call you can't go home you don't have
your kids
so then
um
he tries to fight it
now he's still in court over the whole
thing right but this is where a lot of
men commit suicide
I certainly would think about it if I
was in that situation where they took
out and he's in his 40s and 50s it's not
like he's a young guy I mean how old are
you guys 40 40 40. so you can imagine
everything being like your business
being taken your house being taken your
kids being taken tomorrow
now the question is why is this legal
for her to do this there's no
repercussion like isn't that a fair
question yeah yep
um like why why is it legal for her to
deny access to the kids with no legal
repercussion oh oh actually let me get
through it so let's say let's say he
gets his kids let's say he gets to court
he fights it he wins and he gets if he
doesn't get primary custody which he
only could get 10 of the time so most
likely he loses spends all this money in
all this debt still paying for his old
house
she he could get his kids six days a
month finally the Court gives him his
kids
she can just do it all over again
she can she can just file another
restraining order it takes him a year
and a half the other issue it takes what
what happens to two years without seeing
your kids it's a different child you
don't know what she's been telling the
kid they might not even want to see you
after two years
why is this legal like why why and
that's my question like why on Earth is
this legal like this is an atrocity this
is I started asking my Uber drivers
there are so many Uber drivers that I've
had that talked about how they're
ubering because their ex-wife screw them
over in divorce so why why is this
happening Family Court okay it's not
based on if you're guilty or if you're
innocent it's based on a balance of
probabilities so you can accuse someone
of something with no evidence and no
repercussions and again the women's
group comes in with all their lawyers
the man comes and broke he comes in with
nothing half the time he can't even
defend himself and if he does again
twenty to thirty thousand dollars the
lawyers do not have as best interest at
heart
now he let's say he he gets lucky right
he wins he gets the kids for six days a
month what happens
she can do it over again and it's legal
because the politicians Pander to women
because the biggest swing voting group
is women
and one incentive do the men have do the
politicians have to change the laws when
they're not going to be reelected
and that's happening right in front of
our eyes and what do you think should
should happen instead it should be 50 50
custody off the bat
um I think they should not have free
counsel just like for a b because it you
it went up 200 allegations of abuse went
up 200 in 2013 when they switched that
law in the UK
um so I think that it should be 50 50
custody off the bat and I don't
um in terms of restraining orders I
don't think it should be that easy to
just get a restraining order against a
guy but the problem is in the courts too
is that it's it's based on you only have
to convince one judge and we're in a
society where if a woman cries and is
saying oh he abused me he did this we
just automatically believe them
I mean when's the last time a girl said
to you or anyone in a room that they
were great they were assaulted they're
anything and anyone really asked
questions and I didn't when I first
started the show I just openly believed
women but then you start asking
questions and doesn't add up
and a lot of times at these women's
shelters they're instructing the women
with what to say to get the most money
out of the men and oftentimes that's
accusing them of abuse so you know you
know the idea that like there are
repercussions for women voting and a lot
of times it's at the expense of men
because all of the politicians are
catering to the women because they are
the biggest swing voting group as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible